- Whereas to factor the
polynomial below as the product
of two binomials
and we have n times n minus one plus
3 times n minus one.
So I encourage you to pause this video
and see if you can figure this out.
Well, the key is to realizing
that both of these terms
have n minus one as a factor.
Let me just rewrite the whole thing
so we can work on it down here.
So this is n times n minus one
plus 3 times n minus one.
And notice both of them
have an n minus one,
have an n minus one as a factor.
So what we can do is factor out
the n minus one
or you can view it as undistributing
the n minus one and if we do that,
we're gonna factor out the n minus one
and what are we going to have left over?
Well if you take out the n minus one here
if you undistribute it out,
you're just going to be left with
that n.
So you're going to have an n there
and then for this second term,
you factor this n minus one out.
You're just going to be left with this
positive three plus three.
And just like that we are done.
We have factored the polynomial below
as a product of two binomials.
So this is the same thing as
n minus one times n plus three.
And once again you can check this.
You can take this n minus one
and distribute it.
n minus one times n is
this term right over here
n times n minus one
and then n minus one times three
is this term right over here.
n minus one times three
or three times n minus one.